thank you
[Music]
so
um
there's really not much to say about
this so why'd you pick it then
[Laughter]
oh no Bart doesn't want to see it
anymore [ __ ] like this before
is this another like a ninja was raped
or some [ __ ]
fast used to yourself for all Ryan day
dude if a ninja gets raped though that's
impressive that's all I'm serious about
the story behind this one
you have to sneak around exclusive on
that a Grandma's dying wish I mean just
imagine a Grandma's dying wish was to
have a penis put on her tombstone
nice is that India that's incredible
that's a realistic penis suddenly you're
uh
is it her husband I shared this that's a
big ass dude that's what if if so that's
why she died they got that whole they
got the whole bottom thing too yeah the
stack is made of stone it's huge that
looks modeled after some guy's actual
dick it's a great that guy's got a
chubster for sure
I mean for Katarina that's that's
literally this uh grandma's name she is
99 years old she decided to leave a very
quote distinctive mark on the world that
will leave people remembering her for
years to come was that her like wish
before she was dying because if it's her
dying wish as she's dying you know dying
people kind of say the craziest [ __ ]
right yeah sure she's got like dementia
still her though
and I wonder if she's buried upright
on top of her head dude no if she's
buried where the dick is coming like
from her pelvis oh yeah that's sick
that's how you do it yeah what's going
up and then the thing is she wanted a
hard dick too she didn't want a dangly
dick well she was gonna be like the
Fuddruckers blow up things and [ __ ] like
that so it's constantly malleable I'm
into that yeah
so those are dying wish which means that
you know there's no fact checking on
whether or not she was wishing for this
a long time before her death it was a
dying wish thing yeah do you think it
was like one of those planned ones like
when I die like it's in paper like yeah
in her will yeah like I want the hard
dick or was it like like her [ __ ]
Last Breath was like
did you just say the same thing but
whisper you're like dying
verbally not not in like writing got it
yeah yeah yeah one is like [ __ ] like
with the [ __ ] like a quilt [ __ ]
the feather pen notarized yeah and it's
like or was it broken up in pieces well
she's like I want a hard uh and they're
like
oh dick
I'm gonna put it together gotta put the
whole sentence together
that's it yeah or is it like maybe like
you know God forbid when the time comes
Nikki's Grandma Nikki's Filipino Grandma
Whispers in my ear and she's like saying
some [ __ ] and I'm like [ __ ] I don't
really care
pretty sure it's the garlic but I think
she wants a big hard dick statue over
her grave I don't know I think that's
what she said I know I want to hurt it I
don't know you're gonna make it out you
weren't there I don't know how would you
know that's what we're gonna do one of
her last words
that's what you're getting there too
still okay
what's that mean ladies Mexican by the
way [ __ ] [ __ ] or something uh do
more Indian accents I think okay okay so
weighing almost 600 pounds the massive
Stone member has been called what's
inside of it recognition of her love and
joy for life
Katarina's grandson Alvaro Mota Limon I
don't know why I said oh wait they're
Hispanic yeah said his grandma liked
calling her family verga which is a
Mexican slang word most accurately
translated to [ __ ] they called her
grandma grandma dick
she called everyone she called everyone
dick yeah she she liked calling her
family verga oh hey Dave oh that's cool
yeah that's dope all right so like she
kind of has that Vibe that's a very very
uh fun uh slang that's like Vamos a la
verga yeah it's like we all go to the
[ __ ] or whatever but everybody in Mexico
loves that saying I say it all the time
when I Mexico they love it I think it's
inappropriate but they're like better
guys yeah
if you if you know what I'm talking
about in the comments just go ahead and
write that in English
like let's all go to the penis when you
go visit your uh in-laws
I made it all Italian too
that's good what's the what are the
appropriate uses for that it's one of
those things that's either an insult or
a compliment you know when you call
somebody a [ __ ] oh sorry what's
up [ __ ] or you [ __ ] it's
it's kind of like that in the sense of
saying Vega exit in there like what
there's like some sort sort of like
directional verb what the hell does that
mean it depends though because if that's
a phrase but there guys is a term in and
of itself it depends on the who though
because if I'm a person who doesn't have
very many friends and I hear you refer
to Ryan as a [ __ ]
I'm like oh I probably hate this guy
it didn't used to always be like this
man why are they being wait sounds like
they're bullying each other they're
beefing yeah they're definitely beefing
with each other you can see it the way
he said off camera almost Sophia Vergara
you can tell they have definite beat
because I don't have any friends to
compare this to and uh real friendships
shouldn't have that kind of relationship
speaking very matter of fact just just
wondering so did she die and she has the
Tucson or did she make the tombstone
before she died oh damn she had to make
it herself Barrel she crafted it herself
she killed her
it crushed her killed her I mean I don't
think she uh made it herself okay just
to clarify but uh and we'll just assume
that she's totally dead already and it
just happened we'll just assume okay her
grandson Alvaro uh says that when she
was throwing the word at her family she
meant it to mean that they were people
of Integrity courage passion and at the
same time love and joy that's what
that's what a hard dick means I think so
hey women love it they do they love it
it's Integrity telling people this all
the time they don't really get it yeah
this story helps with that I thought
Middle School boys like dick the most
but now I realize it's Mexican grandmas
Mexican Grandmas this uh she did the
entire census for the for the entire
Mexican grandma population out there you
guys wouldn't want interesting things on
your tombstones a giant velga maybe
more expensive I've seen baking recipes
oh that's nice baking recipes yeah like
people will have their own like dish and
they'll have the recipe engraved on
their Tombstone you know it doesn't look
cool but is cool the QR codes that
you've been seeing on tombstones that's
kind of whack but the idea of being able
to like look it up and then like see
that person's like life in different
ways or whatever they that's kind of
type
change of heart in me now what if the QR
code went straight to JK news
did you guys submit we submitted right
looking good yeah it's looking really
good I hope we win that one it's looking
really good would you would you guys
want to be buried at a graveyard like
like a normal person oh yeah man Rose
Hills all the way oh yeah
what yeah family there is that why like
I don't think I do so you're just gonna
be there by yourself I just think the
idea is cool I think I want to be buried
but then like not this way the other way
and on top of Michael Jackson face down
that's really good face down so Michael
Jackson is down here I'm gonna buy the
space up there and I'm gonna go for you
to buy the vertical spot yeah and then
they're gonna but they have to place you
like in front of them yeah so then I can
finally meet him that's 69. why would
you do that to Michael
you know you should get the body of a 13
year old boy and put it on top of that
true that's true no because they like
because he wants to hang out it's a
little too old it's because they want to
hang out guys I wanted to do the QR code
thing but when um when people look it up
it's like me asking people to solve my
murder
you've just accessed all the clues to my
death please help solve this murder wow
then I really just died of cancer
I can't rest
known as Don yakata grew up in poverty
and was not able to go to school as a
child but nonetheless became an
important person in this area uh her
grandstanding became mayor of the town
for a period of time seeing his grandma
taught her family that they could be
anything they wanted and inspired them
to get education hey Real Talk probably
a weird time to bring this up but I saw
a [ __ ] ghost last night
at my hotel room at the bike no [ __ ]
way I'm not [ __ ] kidding I'm not
[ __ ] kidding it was so crazy I woke
up at like probably five in the morning
and and I'm just like you know on my
side whatever and Nikki's next to me and
I roll over and I look up and there's
just a [ __ ] dude standing over our
bed what is he doing he's just standing
there staring down but look it's a
complete silhouette he's Haitian bro I
don't [ __ ]
he's being real
I'm just I'm just wondering if if
Spirits keep their hair I'm just wearing
I'm just wondering
it was a skinny dude standing over our
bed he was gone he was just Shadow
though I don't know he was skinny right
but yeah it was it was dude I'm telling
you like the shores I'm sitting here it
was the shadow dude staying over bed
there's like um this white lampshade
behind
um like in the corner that was covered
obstructed by him whoa he was blocking
it there's like Moonlight coming in
through the curtains translucenting him
no no translucent [ __ ] it would look
like some dudes in our [ __ ] a regular
guy's dead the [ __ ] dude
no not floating just standing there
staring down and I couldn't even put it
together because just so it's just so
weird I wasn't scared of anything
no I was like what the I was just so
confused I was like what the [ __ ] this
dude in my [ __ ] room here and then I
went there and then I sit up he takes a
step back right [ __ ] off oh I'm not
kidding well whatever it is like he was
moved he moved back I don't know that he
stepped or whatever but he moves back
like so he's closer to where the where
the lampshade is right and then I'm like
[ __ ] confused I like look over here
and look back he's gone whoa
she's sleeping did you feel cold at all
no no no
you guys think we're gonna talk take
your door lock was it locked was your
butthole sore locked everything's
normally yeah I had come all over my
face in my in my tits oh [ __ ] but I
didn't think that that was very weird
did you decide did you switch rooms no
we're going to talk to them we'll see
what if you get charged for having an
extra person
that takes the water from the center you
know they charge your room because he
took the water
no it was so [ __ ] weird was that the
first time ever that was it for a while
there was this there's a there's a story
where when I was a kid
um we were coming in from Virginia to
visit my grandma and I was staying in my
mom's old room in my grandma's home and
I wake up middle of the night same kind
of [ __ ] like there's an alarm clock like
a glow from alarm clock like orange blow
and there's this dark figure standing
over the bed same [ __ ] same person same
[ __ ] but this one if it didn't feel like
this one I felt nothing around right
felt nothing but this one I felt like a
weird sense of like it's all good if the
silhouette matched anybody in your prior
history or family or anything who would
it be bro nobody that I know can you see
the face no [ __ ] no just it's just
Shadow full Shadow so where did he have
a driver's license any noises
but the same [ __ ] right it's the same
[ __ ] of like of like you are confused
you look at it and then you look away
and then it's completely gone but it was
obstructing it was like obstructing the
light that's what happens on acid for me
that's how the that's how the
commissioner feels about Batman yeah
dude you don't look you shouldn't Look
Away Don't Take Your Eyes Off Batman
[ __ ] because as soon as you look away
he's gone he's like you fast back soon
after you woke up where you saw the
[ __ ] figure it was like two minutes
later did you oh so you were kind of I
was up and like like I was like looking
over here and I gotta drink of water
real quick because I had like water by
the bed and then you said you said
excuse me this guy get some water and
then I flip I flip over and that's when
I see this dude in the room and I'm like
what in the absolute [ __ ] because it's
just it's like as short as like anybody
you you like light somebody and there's
just it's just that it's there's no
translucent [ __ ] he's not [ __ ] oh
I'm kind of floating yeah and it's just
like a dude you can't see what the
clothes what if he went away into like
some sort of secret tunnel in your room
you probably wanted to under the into a
secret tunnel yeah but
it's like this fast right it's like boom
boom gone boom boom gone like it just
doesn't make sense boom boom boom let me
hear you say whale whale
foreign